oh hello everybody this is nina basic
i'm from cornell university
and i work in a group that deals with
growing plants in difficult sites human
impacted
mostly urban but very difficult sites
that have been disturbed by
some human activity and so
uh just to give you a little bit of
background in
the summer of 2019 i was asked by the
national park service
to take a look at the flight 93 memorial
landscape
because there were some issues there
they thought needed some improvement and
so i said okay i take a look
i went there for a brief review and then
came back
in october of 2019 to do a
full evaluation so this is the site
you're looking at
um of course we know the terrible day of
what happened
uh flight 93 uh took off from newark
and was headed for san francisco but it
was turned around
to go toward washington dc and the
passengers and crew
struggled for control of the plane and
then it crashed in
shanksville pennsylvania on 2001
that a terrible day so that
very rural site in shanksville
pennsylvania
very very non-populated area
and uh the national park service decided
to
create a memorial there to the 40 people
who died
so this is the overall site
and basically it's a it's almost a
thousand acres it's a very large
site uh and you can see a black
outline perhaps the entire site that the
national park service
manages and you can see the flight path
of where
and the impact of where the crash
actually took place but i want you to
focus on
the green curved area in the middle of
your screen
this represents 40 memorial
groves 40 groves and each of those
groves has 40 trees so it's
1600 trees in that curved
dark green area because memorial grove
and they were planted in 2012.
so this was the area that the parks
national park service wanted us to take
a look at because
there were issues with the trees so
again it was 1600 trees
40 groves of 40 trees so let's take a
look
so first of all i want to mention that
what we do when we go to some of these
sites that need to be looked at we do a
site assessment we have to understand
what the opportunities and limitations
of the site are so
we're going to the site with that idea
in mind
so we get to the site this is some of
the 40 growth these were really good
ones
um so there are trees this was october
early october
in 2019 so there's a little bit of fall
color but this is
a look at some of the trees but
this was a look at a lot of the other
trees
so there were some that were decent
good i would say possibly um
and some that were dead and some that
were dying and some that were in really
bad shape
so it was really striking to us we had
to do we evaluated every single tree
of the 1600s and then we took soil
samples to evaluate what was going on
underground so this is some of the sites
which basically had
no live trees uh again they were planted
all the same time
same year at least and uh
i don't think that was the issue in
terms of timing
so we had ratings for each of the trees
and there's me
and uh this tree would be considered a
good rating
i mean it's not great form or anything
like that but it still
would be considered a good rating this
would be a moderate rating
obviously a lot of dieback and poor form
and uh here we would have a
fair rating which is a lot of dead again
poor form poor growth
and we have a poor or dead rating so
there were these were the ratings we
used to evaluate the trees as well as
taking the species different we had to
identify
all the species that were there too we
had gotten some information from the
national park service about
what people thought were the species but
that turned out not to be
wholly accurate some of the other things
we saw
with this is a red oak gall that looked
like the size of uh
tennis balls and enormous galls on some
of the
scarlet oaks that were there
we saw us these small balls you see
these are the white oak gold so
a lot of these trees although they might
have looked okay
they had a lot of insect infestation
we saw on the ground we saw a sedges
which indicate really poorly draining
sites these were not planted these were
sedges
not grasses that indicate poorly
draining soils
we also saw lichens on many of the trees
which indicate
really slow growth because lichens are
basically are sloughed off when trunks
are growing
and becoming larger but if the lichens
are getting are staying there that means
the growth is not very
rapid and we also a lot of deer rub
damage
here as you can see that where the deer
had rubbed the
trunk and it's trying to close over
after that we saw a lot of deer damage
on these plants
and we saw of course taking so there's
it's a very windy sight
uh which we noticed when we're there and
there's some and these are small trees
that were planted
um so there's an indication that people
tried to do staking but this was not a
good staking method
and many times the stakes are just out
of the ground as you see here
so here's a picture a graphic
of all the 1600 trees each dot is a tree
and you can see and the color coding
denotes the condition of the tree so
from good
moderate fair poor or dead or missing
the purple is missing so
as you can see there's a gradient from
good to
moderate fair and poor as you
go along the
crescent of these plantings which is
interesting to us although
even in the good area the darker green
you see quite a few missing some dead
some
really poor condition but there were
several at the
top of that crescent that were pretty
good but as you go
along the 40 grows it gets worse and
worse
as you uh walk along that the almost two
miles of
groves
so after we did uh initials
tree snapping and i'll tell you more
about the species we found there
we also got a backhoe to do
some soil evaluations we had
six areas where we took two samples at
one each location
one was at the top part of the soil and
one we went deeper about 24 to 36 inches
deep to get a lower uh volume of soil to
test to bring back the cornell to run
through our soil
sampling test some of the things we
noticed though
so there's our backhoe it wasn't
possible to put a shovel in the ground
by the way
um in this these sites they were
very very compacted we tried to do some
simple compaction tests but it was
virtually impossible to
really get a shovel in the ground so we
use the backhoe which is always very
useful
in this situation and we one of the
things we saw
was clot when we started to dig just the
surface we saw clogs
um meaning telling us very poorly
structured soil with no crumbs we have
big clogs of soil
and as you see here this has soil with
no structure
no aggregates
and this is what we want to see of
course we didn't have that but this is
what we would like to see
and then we would actually get it deeper
and we saw coal
so this was an abandoned strip mine
coal strip mine site and which would
mean
surface mining of coal and when we
started to get down
past 12 inches there was plenty of coal
still
in the ground and this was worrying this
was kind of condition that would be
very unusual for 1600 trees to be
planted
in a coal mine but that's what we saw
and the effect of the coal not just
being
difficult for plants to go around has a
chemical effect as well which we found
out later
so this was a abandoned strip mine there
had been no
soil remediation before the trees were
planted
and the result was as we found
we also when we had these big pits
opened we also wanted to do a
percolation test to see
how water drained and i you know the
soil was
heavy and sort of heavy uh silky loam of
clay
and but there were lots of coal in it
and i thought well it might drain
because of all the rocks and the
coal and the soil but we filled these
pits up
and we went away for an hour we came
back and there was virtually
no drainage no perk
down so we filled them up and they
stayed filled up
uh even after an hour which you would
expect to see a little bit
of uh movement but there was none so
this was another
major issue which we had to deal with
and this is a simple test we would do
looking at
inches per hour and again with that big
pit we had no
percolation
so just let me tell you about some of
the trees we found there so there were
two maples there was red maple
and a sugar maple and you can see
that the red maple on the left uh about
35
of those red maples were in pretty good
condition
and that you would note and basically
red maples can deal with
a poor drainage and that would be you
know
basically looking at that issue and with
the sugar maple however
they do not like poor drainage and only
12
of the sugar maples were in good
condition
so we're talking about a lot of trees
here and
beyond that 33 with red maples and 18
with sugar maples
all the remaining trees were
unacceptable
in terms of their growth so a lot of
really poorly looking trees and this was
the best
instance so we had uh
several oaks as well we had chestnut oak
two more of those they had 24
good black oak had virtually no
good trees um so they really did poorly
and then the most numerous group were
the white oak quercus alba
and the scarlet oak crutches coxsenia
and both of them had about 30 percent
good and the rest of them unacceptable
so we
were dealing with a lot of trees at
about 1600
that were considered unacceptable
and this is considering this is seven
years of growth so they were planted in
2012 we
looked at them in 2019 so
it's a lot of years of growth to have
such poor results
so all the trees combined um
407 were good
and all the rest 1200 or so
were poor dead missing
uh or unacceptable growth
so now we look at the trees uh it's
pretty depressing quite honestly
um but you thought there was major
issues here with how the trees were
being
handled on site and a number of people
in the park service said well
it's just species we had to have better
species well
my experience is that uh species is
important
but soil you know basically is the most
important thing
you can have the best trees in the world
but if you have poor soil
that really uh overcomes any kind of
species issues so
we wanted to look at the soil in a very
detailed way and the cornell has a soil
health
test which looks at both the physical
the chemical and the biological
aspects of soil now when often when we
take
soil samples what we're really looking
at is the chemical what are the
nutrients
maybe the ph uh but we're not looking at
the physical and the biological which is
equally if not more important
than just the chemical aspect
so we're looking in the physical
structural stability
uh aeration storage physical
proliferation ability to do that
structure of the soil that comes or pegs
or clogs
uh in terms of biological we're looking
at
potential disease issues organic matter
decomposition
neuralization pest suppression
and in chemical we're actually looking
at nutrient storage and ph
so there are these all these aspects are
important in terms of evaluating the
soil on the site
especially this large site that we're
building
this is the soil health test that does
many
took soil samples large soil samples
that have them run through all these
different tests
that we decided were important
so this is just i'm going to show you
one pic one of the 12
samples into this is one soil sample you
can see on the left
you have the three colors the purple the
green the yellow the purple
or the physical aspects of the soil and
the
column in the middle is kind of stock
like colors you know red is
stopped yellow is moderate and green is
good
so looking just at the colors
we had pretty good water holding
capacity 21 which is uh
pretty good but if it but we had
exceptional
surface hardness of the soil and
subsurface hardness going down
deeper so we had basically no way for
roots to proliferate
in that soil because the soil was
rock-like
also the aggregate stability that's the
crumbs or pes
the aggregate of the soil we had very
very poor
aggregate stability so we had those we
what we saw in a field with those clouds
but no tilth or or pegs or crumbs
that we would like to see we come to the
biological aspect
so we had poor organic matter only three
percent
and then we had uh soil protein and
which basically is a proxy for uh
biological
microorganisms that are mineralizing
nitrogen
we had pretty high root pathogen
pressure another we
actually grew beans in the soil and we
looked at the roots and saw
whether there had been some fungal
problems there and there were
soil respiration is the action of
microbial
activity of microbes that are actually
breaking down
uh the soil into reusable uh
nutrients for plants uh to grow and that
was very very poor so there's very few
microorganisms
an active carbon as a fraction of
the total organic matter which is
the energy source for the microorganisms
so a
portion of the organic matter is
actually the food for microorganisms
and that again was very poor
we'll come to the uh chemical aspects
well the soil ph was
in this case was quite low 4.9 although
we had phs
in the seven so the ph or the acidity or
alkalinity of the soil
was very very varied from all the
different sites we took
but in terms of the phosphorus potassium
and elements
uh nutrients there they were they
weren't bad at all
so if you just took a soil test and
looked at the chemical aspects
you might not think the soil was so bad
but when looking at
all the different aspects of soil it
really is clear that we had a very
very damaging situation
an overall quality score for this was
very low of 34 out of 100
other things we found uh toxic elements
we sound the heavy metals barium
chromium nickel copper zinc
these are interesting we don't see them
in high levels in most soils but because
of the strip line i think that's
why we saw them there these in them
themselves are not necessarily toxic to
plants but
obviously you don't want to be bleeding
in the dust or
handling this so highly but the most
important
thing you saw was highly toxic levels of
soluble salts
now these aren't the icing salts and
sodium chloride these are salts
created by the action of the coal and
the soil
and the weathering over time so we had
highly toxic levels of soil or salt
so not to non-saline or lower abs so it
had been very variable
but there were at least half of the
sites had highly a strongly saline
uh soil and in the soil solution so that
was
very worrying because that's something
that can really kill trees pretty
quickly
so how what do we how we deal with this
we get all this information the
soils the trees and uh there's several
things we can do well
we could have protected soil structure
during construction well that
that bird had flown we couldn't do
anything about that
we needed to think about how much lime
we would need to
remediate to allow our trees to grow
we could replace the soil but that
seemed to be uh
you know out of the budget of uh
of anybody in that area we could amend
the soil but that's
there's something we would talk about we
could vary the soil actually
bring better soil on top and plant into
that
and of course appropriate plant
selection is still going to be an
important
aspect of dealing with compacted soil
so building a building on top or
creating mounds
with good soil as one way to deal with
uh not having to deal with very
compacted soil and porcelain underneath
that didn't seem to be a reasonable
aspect in
this particular grove model we could
have
blended soils and brought new soils in a
very expensive
very enormous amount would have to be
blended to
create a soil that would be good for
plant growth so this didn't seem to be a
reasonable aspect
potential either so
we're basically left with we have to
think about the vine we need
we have to amend the soil be compact and
dilute
when you have highly toxic elements in
the soil
dilution is your best aspect but we also
had to decompact because of the
dense nature of the soil and we had to
think about appropriate plant selection
so these were the ways we wanted to go
so one of the things i'm going to tell
you about is the method we've been
working on
for 20 years and have a lot of research
based on this is called a
very literal scoop and dump method of
soil remediation using a backhoe
on site so what is the sweeping dot
method
so we generally apply a good flavor
layer of compost six to eight inches
of compost two on the top of a compacted
soil
and using a bucket of backhoe bucket we
dig down to at least 18 inches
with into the soil and the bucket is
lifted with the topsoil and compost
and three feet of the air and dumped
down onto the ground
the soil compost mixes then it's kind of
you get veins of compost into this
compacted
soil as cloudy soil then we would plant
directly into that and
surface mulch every year to replenish
organic matter we're adding a lot
of organic matter six to eight inches
out of uh
18 inches is more like a third or more
by volume
of compost into this compacted soil
this is one of the sites we did on
coronal campus which you see after
construction
the soil was basically like concrete and
we
performed this method i'm going to show
you a short video hopefully here
which will allow us to just see what
it's like this is a production of
cornell university
how are you doing
you notice that the soil is still very
rough
we didn't smooth it out or wrote it to
it we're just putting the plants
into that remediated soil
it's always great to have 40 students
doing this kind of work
so this was initially in april of 2014
we'll show you what happens over a few
years
this is uh the end of planting in may
2014
september now
plants are growing
we aim for something called canopy
closure
which is uh the canopies of the shrubs
and trees touching each other so we have
very
little weed
invasion but this is not in anywhere
near canopy closure
so you see the runoff from the parking
lots going into these biosphere
this is uh july of 2015.
we're seeing a lot more growth we're
getting near canopy closure in some
aspects
and this is uh two years after planting
really a campy closure we have very
little
weed integration we have some
weeds on the edge where the asphalt is
but basically
the plants are pretty well knitted
together and are growing really well
i mean really good growth
having been in a very compact assault
before that
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu
so we've used this scoop and dump method
for over 20 years with good results but
we actually did a research study on it
uh covering the 12 years of this method
and we looked at soils that we had
done the scoop and dump and versus those
that had not been
amended and we looked at what happened
in the soil
we knew the plants were going well but
saw was interesting to show
so first we look at aggregate stability
which is that
you can see the bottom the clogs when
poor stability
and the action of rain water just sort
of melts the
particles of soil away which becomes
recompacted
and on the right you see the crumbs or
heads of the soil with good structure
which allows water to drain through and
roots to grow through
so we were looking at this aspect and we
had very poor
as you remember in that uh soil results
we had very poor aggregate stability in
our
test soil we want to look at
uh these pegs or crumbs basically are
the space between them allows for
drainage and root growth so this is a
critical aspect of soil that we're
always looking for
and you can see in the uh in our amended
soil for after 13 years we had really
good active stability
and in our unamended we had very poor
aggregate stability
72 percent uh in the
amended versus 34
in the unamended organic matter is a
critical aspect of soil and we had
pretty poor
levels of organic matter in our
site soils about 3 and so this
able enables to feed the microorganisms
and to actually
help with uh dedensifying the soil
so we looked at that scoop and dump
you'd expect we're adding all this
compost so we had eight percent uh
organic matter which is by weight so
that's really a lot of
organic matter versus uh 3.2 with the
unamended which is very much like our
site
uh in shanksville
we have active carbon which is the
portion of the organic matter this is
actually going to be feeding the
microorganisms
that are going to be doing the heavy
lifting of making these uh
organic matter and minerals available to
plants in terms of nutrient availability
so
the and also in terms of aggregate
stability so
this is the portion of the organic
matter that's really important to feed
those microorganisms
so we had again uh high levels of
active carbon and low levels of
active carbon in the unamended soils
water holding capacity wasn't the
problem too much we had 21
water available water holding capacity
in our test site
um and but in fact we did get a little
bit more organic
water holding capacity with our scoop
and dump it's about 23
which is very much like the shanksville
site
potentially mineralizable nitrogen i'm
not going to go through the nitrogen
cycle with you but
basically we're looking at uh moving
ammonia to ammonium so that plants can
take it up
and that's microorganisms again aren't
doing that
for us so potentially mineralizable
nitrogen
again very good with the scoop and dump
and very poor with the unamended
soil the surface hardness
we use a field penetrometer
to actually push into the soil and get a
reading
in pounds per square inch anything over
300 pounds per square inch means that
roots cannot penetrate through it so
it's
it's a measure of the usable depth
of plant soil and so in this case we had
virtually no
usable soil in terms of density
on the shanksville site
in our research we get much more dense
uh reduction in density
with the uh sweeping down
bulk density is a another measure of
density that we take
and this is just showing a field
application where you have
denser soil where it's been plowed and
on the right
you see more uh crumbs and heads
on the on the right it's on the far
right
so we're looking at the density of the
soil it was very hard to
take the density because of all the
rocks but in our research we found that
we had a much lower which is good
with a lower density in the scoop and
dump and a much higher density
in the unamended soil
so over time was interesting so we did
this the results i just showed you is an
average of 12 years
but we wanted to see what happened over
time from the first year to the 12th
year
and this is showing a scoop and dump
operation but what happened over time
my thought was that it would be best at
the beginning when you just
like just densified the soil and then
put in the organic matter and you have
the lowest density but in fact it was
much more different different than i
expected so here you have the bottom
is the years since the are scooping down
from
0 to 12 years and you have the density
and what we want without density is
lower not higher so the lower it goes
the better it's the least dense and you
can see that over 12 years
we had lower density than we did at the
beginning which was really surprising
and it's showing that the microorganisms
in the soil which were feeding with this
active carbon
are actually creating heads or crumbs
which can actually
increase or decrease the density and
improve
the bulk density we also saw active
carbon that food source for
microorganisms
over time we're getting more um
active carbon based on the way that the
compost is being break
broken down to feed microorganisms so
these are very encouraging results
so amending incorporate at least a third
to 50
by volume so this is not putting in a
little sprinkling of
compost you have to provide enough
compost to really make a difference in
terms of the density
we amend over a site never amend a hole
at least 18 inches depth with the
sanctuary we're going to recommend
24 inches depth and we have to think
about excess
drainage whether you choose plants that
can tolerate wet
soil conditions or provide other kinds
of drainage
apparatus back to shanksville
uh we have an idea of what we want to do
uh and we propose this to the national
park service it has not been done yet
since
everything came to a halt last year but
we would take one
grow one of the 40 grow
when it grows with 40 trees and remove
everything which is basically dead to
begin with
and then oh here's a 40 growth five rows
of eight trees each each
tree thirty feet apart you go down
uh put eight inches of compost and a ten
foot wide band
uh of these 240 feet
long basically alleys for trees
we would then take a backhoe put eight
inches on and go down 24 inches so again
a third by volume
of compost to soil 24 inches down
and incorporate compost with the soil
at a very high level to dilute some of
those toxic elements
we would do this over one entire grow
and we still have the same uh design
location where the trees would be
there's eight trees in a row until we
get 30 feet apart
and then we would mulch the entire strip
so to increase the organic matter as it
gets used up
so the organic the mulch on top actually
increases the organic matter down below
as long as you have microorganisms
doing all that good work
so we just have to think about plant
selection as my last part here
uh we can choose plants that are have
fewer diseases or insects we can
choose plants that are different sizes
have heat and cold
uh different uh abilities to tolerate
heat and cold
we can tolerate we can choose plants
that can tolerate poor drainage that's
the important thing because we know even
though we're going to amend the soil
we're still going to have poor drainage
down below that
and dry soils yes you can choose trees
that can tolerate
dry soils up to a point ph yes you can
definitely choose trees that have
different abilities to tolerate the
acidity or alkalinity of the soil
so somewhat that's a hard one because we
have high
sailing salts in this spot but
compaction
cannot choose plants that can tolerate
the density that we found there
so here's a few trees that we think
might be good
it's not the only ones but these
tolerate in fact when we were on the
site
we saw a black locust everywhere on this
um this uh national park service area
so it's a native pennsylvania it's a
plant that fixes its own nitrogen and
makes its own nutrients if you like in
the soil
it tolerates high salts poor drainage
and drought
uh so it's one of the possible trees
uh honey locust gladix is also one that
can tolerate
poor drainage up to a point and can
tolerate some salts
which is another big issue here
uh gymnocrattus diocus kentucky coffee
tree another
good tough tree for uh
to tolerate some salts and tolerate some
poor drainage and drought
and very alkaline and acid soil uh
uh compatible so it doesn't have a
problem with
varying phs of the soil as do the other
ones
godzilla or rabinea
and liquid ambar uh sweet tone is
another possible
uh tree for this site great for color
but it also tolerates some poor drainage
and we'd have to look at the make sure
the distortion planted in
place where the ph is very high it
doesn't tolerate a really high ph
but it tolerates moderate to low ph so
this was another
and then there's several hybrid elements
that are resistant to dutch elm disease
and elm yellows that would be
really good uh possible trees for this
site
so that's just a few there may be others
uh oh yeah this is one i thought i'll
put in tyrus gallegano
which is has a very bad reputation
because it tends to fall apart
and it's invasive there's a new cultural
called chastity
cute name for a sterile form of
calorie pair so this is one we think
would be a great
addition as well so proposed actions
amending the soil using scoop and dump
for a test grow over 40 trees choose at
least four species to assess growth over
two to three years stick and protect
trees from deer
damage and wind use one and a half to
one and three-quarter caliper trees
either b
or container grown so they're a bit
bigger to start with
um and they have a better way of getting
started and re-mulch
every year water as needed depending on
what the season is like
so these are the proposed actions and um
i think we'll leave it there as to what
we saw we evaluated
we're proposing actions to try to
remediate this very difficult site